hey welcome to the Reuben report i'm
dave rubin but you can call me Carlos
danger we have a great show for you this
week did you hear about the Royal baby
did you hear there's a baby a royal baby
can you believe it I've got two great
guests for you junior Jackson from the
TYT all-star team making his first
appearance on the Reuben report I'm just
trying you know I gotta spread out
welcome to the show pic and first time
you were the first time to Pete guest
you are now the first time three-peat
guests miss Kelly Carlin is right here
beside me consecutive right yes there's
never been a back to back in second
guess but maybe if you guys are pressing
up we could be really impressed today we
can we could make it maybe it can be
pulled up alright so let's get right to
it the big news of the week the Royal
baby and that of course pushes
everything else out of the way Kate
Middleton and Prince William they had a
kid the kid is now more powerful and
richer than you will ever be and CNN and
all the other news organizations want
you to know that the coverage has been
endless and it's gonna it's going to
continue even this morning CNN had on
their chyron that uncle what's is the
uncle the Hat Uncle Harry he plans on
being a responsible but fun uncle so did
it we get besides the bay as they're
very loyal yet we see in the poop I
don't know all right so there's a lot of
ways we can go at this but let's just
start with the general thing what is our
obsession as Americans with the royal
family it seems a little ludicrous
considering we left England originally
because we didn't want to be under the
auspices of a royal family I have
theories about this give me a theory so
my theory is is that a we are a little
jealous you know so our celebrities are
royalty now and this country but I
really do believe that you know kind of
archetypal II we have this king queen
thing that we want to have a
relationship with and they fit right in
it's like oh look there they are we can
have that and in America we can kind of
have our cake and eat it too you know
what I mean it's like we don't have to
have any Royals we get to borrow the
Royals if we like it right but we sort
of treat our presidents now and
especially Obama as
royalty right well yeah where's I guess
what's up benefit in doing it at least
our benefit and we have a royalty of
course there's the Bush family that have
been this melted yeah yeah exam
embarrassing that is yeah I mean went
from from HW to w possibly Jed and and
then gym I'm sorry yeah yeah I can I
mess up the wrong family it's definitely
a jetted yeah mmm taxes and now wait
yeah and then so then we push our
Clinton's we had a continent and it
hiccup for a second but we might bring
the next one back yes it's it's more
things where we out we have to we have
to have this connection to the same
group to fill this reverence to and we
do which is our politicians in general
which is why politicians can't do
anything human and mess things up
because like well you're a politician
yeah it's fine but we see this royal
family is immaculate yeah they have now
the perfect baby and we love the pomp
and circumstance you know we do we have
our flag waving and the Jets coming by
and he get all misty eyed and and you
know and there's a lot of angle files in
this country but the amount of cover I
literally I tweeted yesterday because I
was like I went on to CNN like this like
barely like okay let's check it out and
I watched it about 30 seconds oh it was
like anti-mouse yeah because it was just
so insane they had a woman on who they
claimed was their royal correspondent
this is CNN who also closed their
Baghdad Bureau so that tells you really
that tells you a lot about what yeah so
i'ma I'm of two minds of this cuz on one
hand it seems crazy you know you're just
this is just this rich family that is
taking and taking and taking from
society and while they have all kinds of
economic problems there as we do here
and then on the other hand I think there
might be something good about it because
they get to get out the cult of
personality on these people where we
want obama to not only be a president
and function and do stuff but also be
our hero so I kind of think it might be
good do you do you buy that theory a
little bit haha that's I'm trying to you
don't know trying to yeah does that make
any sense to you that maybe they get
some of their gossip stuff out all the
stuff that we push you know we want
obama to be this perfect man and play
basketball perfectly and speak properly
and be funny where they get some of the
cult of personality all that personal
stuff
with the royal family because they don't
really have jobs so they can you know
that way their prime minister can focus
on actually working some importance on
them because they don't do much I guess
is the situation I mean at least we have
a dual use of our leaders in olive oil
here's the thing that I finds really
interesting about this particular royal
family is that I've watched an amazing
documentary about them and when they
when Queen Elizabeth was raised her
father said to her if we are gonna have
any purpose in this culture we have to
be of service to to this country she was
trained from day one every single day
she is of service she goes out into the
community and does something and they
and they do try to raise their people up
and they do try to connect with them and
in a very connecting people way and
although they're rich and they get all
that land and all jewels and all that
kind of stuff and they did and it's a
fairytale castle full of gold that they
swim in that oh yes I think in some ways
there it's like a more tangible service
that they're in with their people than
even our own politicians who it becomes
all about politics and taking sides and
now it's ridiculous because nothing
works right I think they hold kind of a
vacuum or an interesting kind of a place
where there's a space where they
actually can be idealized in some way
you know so I think you're kind of right
about the cult of personality would that
work for us to do we need to take away
some power from these guys for a
power-hungry and then control our life
right we need to make them well there
are a lot of the more figureheads
they're controlled by other powers
anyway those are hidden yeah right so
out right there it's a little more out
front so so last thought of this and
this is what you were touching on
earlier why is it that our media and
this goes to a much bigger problem that
you know we've had three weeks of
non-stop 24-hour Zimmerman coverage fine
then we've had Royal baby coach her last
two days and then yesterday amazingly
the Royal baby got knocked off because
of wiener / or dick basically um why
can't we balance two things at once I
don't want to completely dismiss the
importance of a royal baby okay it's
fine but why can't we do a little of
that and a little this we have to do
24-hour coverage of everything because
we're a bunch of Schmucks I the shortest
attention span of anyone I'll know if it
spreads to also British folks and when
they have their coverage I'm sure their
coverage is just as insane price
worse yeah but I think the only way that
the only reason we have this one track-
cuz that's what we've been pushed and
then they form our brains if they give
us two things our brains will learn to
adapt right maybe we can absorb and and
and consume two things at once and
actually thoughtfully put it through our
brains but until we get it we're not
going to be able to handle it yeah do
you agree do you think it's just a fetus
crap so we just eat crap pretty well I
think the structure of media is a
corporate structure it's all about
ratings it's not about informing people
so this is what we get yeah do you guys
remember there was apparently a
revolution in Egypt a couple weeks ago
we were gonna have a no-fly zone in
Syria did you know Detroit went bankrupt
but there's wrong baby the story of that
day the day when the baby was born not
unborn unnamed baby the baby was on
board oh yeah really hope his name is
Gary yeah yeah will the help his name is
Lamar but yeah that would ease of it the
the biggest pet story there was one of
this I hate when people say so while you
guys are talking this nonsense you know
a real story happened but that day there
was a prison break at Abu Ghraib and
they got they released space 500
prisoners with trucks backed in
explosives and RPGs and machine guns and
firefights I said this is like I mean if
anything this is a sensational stories
you can cover it and say usually this
bad ass five double grave but they
didn't even do that but they didn't even
do that right well I'll put a cap on
this by saying that I saw a tweet from
Anderson Cooper last night he was saying
coming up on a 3 ac360 and it was Royal
baby anthony weiner and a man who almost
got swallowed by a whale so that's
what's going on over there okay let's
let's move on oh I love this one so I
ran that wonderful beacon of justice and
freedom and fairness in the world that
is putting out so much positivity and so
many good things and is wonderful to
women and gays and all that good stuff
they're not happy with America's well
the trayvon martin george zimmerman
verdict and the Iranian Foreign Ministry
has released a statement on the verdict
the acquittal of the murder of the
teenage african-american once again
clearly demonstrated the unwritten but
systemic racial discrimination against
racial religious and ethnic minorities
in the u.s. Society the court ruling has
also seriously put under question the
fairness of the judicial process in the
United States now many Americans
actually would agree with that and I
agree with part of it of course but it's
a little odd that Iran where literally
they stone women to death you can be put
to death for being gay I mean I don't
have to go on and on the list of human
rights violations over there that
they're doing this is this just all you
know over-the-top bravado because they
want to do anything to make the us look
bad or divert attention from the nuclear
situation this is the Don said as you
said many Americans would agree with
that yeah I'm one of them but the thing
is is because it comes from this type of
source then it's very easy to write off
and then for the people who do agree
with it or don't want things to change I
don't want a certain level of fairness
to rise in our country's judicial
process yeah they'll say well you know
where that came from so now you agree
with Iran who has all of these human
rights violations and intimidation
factors for opponents of their
government yeah that's a great point so
the people that are backing Zimmerman
you're actually strengthening is now
right yeah that's what they do they just
pump us together but I think you really
have to pay attention to the statement
itself and they talked about the
unwritten aspect of racial now see the
thing is in Iran it's written yeah it's
an laws so what they're saying is
actually really they they have a point
they have a beef like if you're gonna be
this prejudice and you're gonna have
this kind of a culture be upfront about
it just like we are right because they
are and the fairness in their country
there's not a lot of fairness in their
country we claim fairness here so I
think they have a point in an innocence
because they're saying walk your walk
you know walk your talk if you're going
to talk a certain way then really live
that but clearly your laws do not live
up to these things you talk about in
your country right is that legit though
in any way or is it or well it's just
not a legit right it's just absurd began
but but I was like not to say it doesn't
have a degree of truth in the essence
yes I don't know if that was a guy there
point but when you look at the semantics
of that statement you're like they do
use specific words you know written you
know unready I mean this is these are
things to think about
highlighted by when people want to bring
up the issue i want to change something
that the way we do things in the country
it's just quiet you know that was a jury
you cannot disparage the decisions of
the jury there's citizens why can't I
disparage the city's the decisions that
citizens made especially after I hear
that one of them was completely
off-kilter and thinking connecting with
one particular outside of this case and
then completely disconnected with the
other your truck might be three SS yes I
mean it's an indication of what our
society is in this country is so that
you can once you I can't we point that
out yeah do you think we're just reaping
what we sow here in America now because
we tell everybody what to do all the
time so even though it's absurd for us
to take a directive on morals from Iran
I mean this is what we push across
everywhere so we're just getting it back
right absolutely and everyone's got an
opinion nowadays so Iran's got an
opinion also but you know I was thinking
this the other day about you know how
everyone hates jury duty in this country
we hate it we do everything we can to
get out of it right and then a decision
like this comes down and we get pissed
about it well if we really want our
justice system to change we need a
citizens to take responsibility and we
need to start understanding that being a
member of a jury is our responsibility
and a great privilege in this country
yes that we actually have eight we do
have a jury system and most of the time
it works right because 12 people this
was only six people in the Zimmerman
thing but 12 people come together and
work it out and try to interpret the law
the best we can and I'm just kind of
sick and tired of people pissin and
moanin about juries and you know right
what happens to you could clearly be
ours because it could be like how it is
in Iraq we're just judges and they just
do whatever they want and we have those
kind of any others there's two people in
the country who would do jury duty every
week my parents they the jury summons
comes like use they're excited yeah I
mean they watch the judge shows and then
they watch the judge took dramas and
they grew up in a time when it was as
may be as explicit as Iran's laws are
against certain minorities yes and
they're like oh we do I want to be on
this joy yet to give me the case right
that's really funny you know I was
called in for jury duty a couple of
months ago when i was living in new york
steel and the entire time i kept
thinking and I wanted to
out of it naturally and the entire
because I'm not as good of a citizen as
you want us all to be but I kept me in
the entire time could i plead comedian
to them because i can't sit there and do
this the way regular people you're my
everything about me is going to try to
make fun of the system and i'm gonna use
this in a bit you can't have that truth
getting out there and i thought but
needless to say i didn't get picked no
there you go alright so i ran you know
keep on doing what you're doing and okay
all right you know legally here at the
rubin report we have to do one story on
the gays per week so here we go russia
has actually been doing a ton of
anti-lgbt stuff lately all kinds of
crazy laws are coming through it is now
illegal to admit homosexuality in public
this is just a few of them that have
just come in it's illegal to equate the
value of homosexual homosexual
relationships with that of heterosexual
relationships punishment doesn't apply
solely to russians even foreigners can
be arrested and detained find and
deported for homosexual activity now the
reason I'm bringing this up is because
as you guys may know the Winter Olympics
in 2014 are going to be in sochi russia
and a lot of people are calling for a
boycott of the olympics because of this
so the ioc the international olympic
committee has issued a statement the
international olympic committee is clear
that sport is a human right and should
be available to all regardless of race
sex or sexual orientation the games
themselves should be open to all free of
discrimination and that applies to
spectators officials media and of course
athletes we would oppose in the
strongest terms any move that would
jeopardize this principle okay that
sounds really nice but naturally there
aren't going to be any openly gay
Russian athletes for sure there are a
couple openly gay athletes that we had
in the summer olympics but the question
is now that's just the statement it
doesn't sound like they're going to do
anything about this and does the IOC
have even the power 20 for the 2014
Winter Games are coming I mean this is a
matter of months at this point can we
actually do anything or should we
actually do
what do you think yeah I don't think
they can do anything I mean I suppose
the LGBT community could come up with
something boycotting or something like
that but I mean every single country
that the IOC goes into there's some sort
of horrific compromise i mean you know
they're going to be going to brazil for
the summer olympics that's going to be
very interesting uh and and this is just
you know it's like it's one thing about
creating a the semi market economy here
in Russia now they're trying to you know
open up but you can still see the
mentality and and the horrific
oppression going on in that country and
and it seems to be actively getting
worse that's the reason this isn't my
darker and darker like this isn't like
an Arab country where things have been
completely backwards this is what was a
country that was becoming westernized
yea years ago that's going the other way
and what in the article what was the
percentage of people if in the culture
who think that absolutely homosexuality
is like bad were like 74 yeah 16 16
think oh it's okay yeah I mean that's a
small amount of peeps it's a very
interesting culture and it's one that I
don't think we can really wrap our heads
around here in the West yeah so Jared
what do you think the IOC should do
because I mean just in terms of time
forget the just in terms of logistics
they can't switch the Olympics at this
point and we deal with tons of countries
that do all kinds of horrible that's the
hard part I because I maybe I'm maybe
I'm hoping for too much but the way they
say sport and the Olympics it brings the
world together you know regardless of
where you're from or what your
background is its kind of what your job
is so I mean and maybe you can eliminate
it because there's a lot of countries in
this world and then maybe I assume you
supposed to know be research these
countries before you dedicate an
Olympics to them alright this just
started I mean maybe this it was
probably four years ago maybe eight
years ago that they decided to go to
Russia for this particular this has
gotten worse since the decision with me
yeah it wasn't like it was great and
then it got kind of bad and now it's
worse y'all think it was ever awesome
yeah yeah Norma Beulah say cut these
countries have the IOC in and the games
in because it's a big PR campaign well
this isn't working well for Russia but
now though because they they know what
they're doing and is it that they're
trying you know so much has changed for
gay rights and especially it just in the
United States alone this past couple
months and in England just passed gay
marriage so are they making a stand that
they really are doubling down like we're
the real still but you know wall
majority and they'll be on the you know
they'll be on the back edge of that
because it you know the world is
changing you know and and there is
something about the idealism of the
Olympics I think about you know we're
gonna come and we're going to be role
models anyway we have an oh it's like an
open society I've heard athletes talk
about it's like this perfect world you
live in for two or three weeks while
you're there yeah and you you are
crossing there's no nationality but
there really isn't because you're all
athletes so I think that is a positive
thing and I think that does shift energy
in some way and I think the people from
Russia who come and have that experience
you know maybe some Minds will be
shifted and that is a real shame is
because I'm a firm believer that all of
the athletes they could they dedicate
their lives especially Olympic athletes
they dedicate their lives often for very
little or no money to to their sport so
they don't care if the person that
they're that's that they're playing
badminton with her give me a winter
sport than bank that is the news do they
care that the other guy on the luge okay
I mean that just doesn't seem nice years
though you know you have an edge of the
ice skating yeah um do you think partly
that this story won't get that much
traction because of a little bit of gay
fatigue because I have a little of this
myself that we've come so far just in
the last few months so many good things
have happened here in American again I'm
not trying to make everything about
America but it also happened in England
and it's happening around the world
South America other places that maybe
you just have to let some things go that
maybe the the gay think has to just sort
of let this one go and keep working on
the other
I think it actually balances itself out
I mean you have you have people that are
pushing every day because that's their
life that's what they're trying to do
and then so then you have people as you
said maybe have the fatigue but in the
people that are pushing the people that
are pulling back you may be gonna find a
balance no one should pull back if they
believe in what they're doing because
it's what's needed it's what has to
happen so in this happening you have to
it's going to slowly change it does
maybe not right away which is because we
have a lot of people that are tired of
it or just are [ __ ] hateful you need
to pick your battles to win the war and
this is okay this is one it's one but
there's been a lot of battles 1 recently
and it's okay to actually enjoy that
yeah and you think it might actually
strengthen the war if you lose this
battle because if you don't allow gay
people to participate or if you're
jailing gay people that show up to you
actually are strengthening the movement
for equality I think this could now
there's a spotlight yeah just to say
what's gonna happen I mean there was a I
think one of the one of the LGBT come
the groups and the in these articles was
saying this is gonna get serious it was
just giving a warning shot this is gonna
get serious yeah and left it alone and
when I get serious and who knows what
may happen hope nothing yeah then people
gonna remember hey they said there's
gonna be serious maybe we should listen
these guys right unfortunately sometimes
you need some bad stuff to happen to get
to get good stuff coming up a little all
right let's let's talk about porn google
glasses which we've also been talking
about a lot lately so they're coming and
it is going to change privacy the way we
know we're all gonna be walking around
recording everything every time you look
at somebody you can snap a picture of
them anthony weiner is going to love
this thing but the first porn videos are
on their way being shot with Google
Glasses X biz and me candy have come out
with a little trailer this is a comedy
porn trailer for what their porn will
look like let's take a look
my class you're taking it one day Oh
Robert hurt it so much better
I like the word for giving up tips right
maybe I should have said NSFW before
that video but okay anyway so yeah that
is going to be the future of porn it's
very obvious you're going to see it it's
all gonna come right out of your eyes
that sounded weird that any who are you
excited about the future of porn is the
is the third person camera it's too
we've all seen it already you want a
google glass on your face and get right
up in it I think maybe because this was
like you said a comedic version of what
will be yes don't really know exactly
what it's gonna be I'm still missing it
I picture those people naked can you
picture that and looking down at the
genitalia yes isn't that the porn part
yeah we're like supposed to be looking
at the genitalia I mean you really can't
figure out what this is gonna be like
and of course this is pre-recorded soul
as a person looking at wherever they
want to look and this again these
logistics that inquiring minds would
like to know yeah but also and in the
funny part of it i think was you know he
checked out her shoes and he said all
you can get these for different rights
all these things that was that was the
best part of that I thought right so in
those will it linked to oh yeah the
saints say a woman is watching the
points I like that uh that lingerie set
and actually does look at it and you
will look it up and you will be able to
buy it so porn is gonna truly become a
multitasking thing because born right
now is one thing you're right you'll be
able to sell since I'm gonna be selling
butt plugs right during right during the
porn thing that's the first time we've
said butt plugs on there so proud aren't
you proud of me Dad um so uh the google
glass thing just in general yeah i am
not wanting this for our culture i do
not want this i am afraid of it we were
talking tivo earlier just how that
changed our life i was at a big event a
big YouTube event guy was walking around
with the google glasses all I kept
saying all night was who's the [ __ ]
in the Google glasses which he had
recorded in upward he probably did but
this is not good this is not okay I'm
not happy with this stop okay so let's
we'll we'll get back to the porn part a
second but let's follow that for a
little bit so yes I completely agree I
don't even think we
even the slightest grasp on how deeply
this is gonna change how humans interact
in two years from now we're all wearing
these we're gonna be recording
everything constantly there will be no
private conversations I mean we've
already lost half of that between NSA
and all that stuff that's something else
altogether uh what's your general
thoughts on the the Google as this idea
of everything being recorded and
uploaded in track and just I'm thinking
everything I we just want our cell
phones think about the the evolution of
a cell phone I remember just in college
and I graduate no to our first phone
still had the green screen there sighs
this while I stood them open yeah and
just where it's grown since then in
these 11 years and where this is this
the base version this is the arcade
version of Google glasses and what's on
it next you know you have people with
their phones filming people without them
knowing it upskirts and all that stuff
put it on their toes and walking under
women this is all I mean so with just
glasses on your face people just wore
dark sunglasses you don't know where
their eyes are right so when this goes
there recording now whatever it is and
we're basically creating a matrix we're
creating the matrix the movie the matrix
that's what we're creating we're all
recording everything constantly we're
creating this alternate digital world
and who's gonna control it and own it
and look scary I'm hoping this'll help
us all learn to say no to this just
rampant progressive technology that
we're not getting to vote on we're not
getting to decide how its effect how it
like the long term 2 5 10 20 years out
the stuff exponentially you know
progresses in an incredible way we need
to stop saying no to some of this stuff
and just yes it's cool fine but just
because it's cool doesn't mean it's
going to help us survive as a species
when do we stop speaking to each other
right right i mean this is all of us
ultimately becoming those fat people in
Wally remember the movie wall-e where we
all end up in these chairs and we order
our big soda and this is mike
bloomberg's nightmare but yeah mom but I
agree with you and I don't I don't know
is that has there ever been a technology
that's been given to us or created or
invented that we didn't use you mean
anything that's ever sanitation really
that's the one because they were quality
better than everything else we rejected
them for some reason exactly no more
really besides beta Japs that is really
the only I mean everything if we come up
with the technology to create a nuclear
bomb we do drop it yeah I mean is there
anything that we that I mean that's sort
of just what humanity is and maybe
that's why ultimately we're gonna
destroy ourselves when because we just
can't stop exercising imagine if you and
now say when who has a smartphone
ninety-eight percent of population maybe
that's too high of a number I'd go with
85 a lot of people I'll go with 80 but
the thing is when you see someone if
they walk Darcy with the Nokia square
brick phone yes you're gonna make fun of
them to their face you're gonna go [ __ ]
is this guy Kerry and so now everybody's
walking with their google glasses in 10
years and their Google super glasses
plus and you don't have anything on your
face and you look at this example is
wrong with you and you gotta go get it
because the the Google store down the
street just let it just release this new
there's your promotion right 20 you
loopy hundred dollars and it's actually
a thousand after ten more years you can
rest of it off everybody you have to
have an hour assyrian music i I don't
believe in a god but I will pray to God
that we turn we don't turn our culture
into this you will pray to the thing you
don't believe that's how upset I am
about these things yeah yeah all right
well let's bring it back to porn for one
second here let's bring um so you know
google has already said that they're not
going to have porn apps in their app
store so me candy I think that's a
that's an Android app store that's gonna
deal with the porn stuff but why is it
that these companies are so anti-porn
I'm we don't expect morals to come from
my technology companies like apple and
samsung and google but yet they feel the
need to block that stuff instead of just
letting us click a box saying I'm over
18 it is interesting because the porn
industry has always been the leadership
in new technology they with uh VHS tapes
they changed you know a partially killed
beta pretty much yeah you know and
everything the internet they were
leaders in the internet and I didn't
kill master beta
so it is interesting but i think it is
these these technology companies saying
you know no we want to guide you know we
want to be in charge of of how we
control the minds of the future uh but
is it a more are they been running some
moral stand here you can imagine it's an
interesting moral stand they're still
afraid ups are our knee-jerk society Oh
penis maybe we talk about how the whole
conversation changed for news because
anthony Weiner's penis is back and yes
so soon if it's anything with sex you
have to go well we don't have anything
to do with sex because you know that
would disparage our reputation because
America is fun we don't have sex in
America yeah we just obsess on it 24
hours a day everything we do is we hide
it so in doing that if you're out from
with it you're gonna be considered you
know there's a bunch of dirty names for
you you know you're a smut peddler yeah
you know so smut peddlers cannot be
associated with this technology company
we're doing this for informational
purposes we're Google right all right
we're doing something lofty and good
here for Humanity they've got to have
government regulation on board to do
whatever they want with their technology
and as we know there's a lot of people
in government these days who have a lot
to say about bodies you know a lot of
the people the right wing don't want
anything to do with bodies and smut and
women and all of that and and I think
it's a general also just thinking about
it how disconnected we are from our
bodies anyway and technology disconnects
you even more that it's kind of
interesting that they're like we don't
even want you connecting to like the
most basic thing about your body with
our technology right and just wait you
know we're in the middle of this Weiner
gate to right now I mean just wait he
was doing it on Twitter but no time will
come when somebody on google glasses
there's gonna be a girl kneeling beneath
some senator you looking up at the way
that'll be exciting to see your Senators
penis on a Google glass yeah cuz he's
signing some bill that he never read you
narrating me know I read the bill and
then your last letters when which they
get hacked now you can give you a glass
in someone else someone down the street
is now got your eyesight yeah wow so
good new Daisy crazy i see this works
please
all right well let's actually let's
stick with privacy for a little bit so
black boxes which are usually thought of
as in airplanes that's where they get
all the data after there's a crash or
something right now they're actually in
ninety percent of all new vehicles sold
in the United States which is a crazy
amount and by 2014 if the national
highway traffic safety administration
has its way it'll be an all new cars
sold in America and I think this is
interesting because it goes to all this
privacy stuff that we've been talking
about you know the government's watching
your meta data on your emails and on
your phone calls and then in just in
terms of with the car you know if you
have ez pass or one of those things they
know when you're what bridge you're
going over and when you're doing it and
now they're gonna have the black box
which is going to tell them how fast
you're going and you know if you went
through a red light and all that stuff
does this ever end I mean this again is
the technology thing but does this stuff
ever really end in any sort of good way
for for regular people I would think it
it was it's okay to a point but the
problem is as soon as the insurance
companies came in and said they'd like
to know about how this is working yeah
and we're gonna spew a safety I don't
trust any insurance company I missed you
I imma do the store really quickly my
car was scratch in a parking lot when
you leave your keys with the attendant
it was a lot of people's at work is our
last few lots ago and I asked my said
did you scratch you guys don't know when
that happened so I said someone must've
scratched by it so I go through their
insurance company for a lot it's like
well you know you own a lot is there
some way through this the first response
I mean before they even assess the
information was not pleased why would be
our fault has none do this yeah when
it's in your leg I mean idea yeah but i
would i would enjoy if you at least act
like you looked at the situation yes you
know pretend like you're doing your job
yeah so the i don't trust them I'm
worried with my black box my way you're
saying because the black box will record
the scratch and then you'll be able to
the reason is because I know that guy
who's thinking but what do they do to
fiddle with this black box there's
technology behind the black box right
and can I trust what information they've
collected from this black bloc because
the nurse 8jr you 100 miles an hour like
I swear i was going 65 right so they'll
be able to tag you for speeding all the
time again no
bridges you're going over and how fast
you're doing it and you're using google
maps are ready to get wherever you're
going so they know where you're going I
want to play everything into this
paranoid yeah state but it's all sort of
legit and we kind of need to talk about
it right and it once again it's the
slippery slope with this stuff it's like
oh well it's in there how do we go back
how do we draw a line with this I mean
this is a device in my car that I own I
own that device and you're telling me I
have no control over the information in
spite of it what's up cuz you go right
there right because if you want a car if
they get their way every a choice to
turn it off can I am I allowed to do
that can i opt out wouldn't that maybe
that would be a nice little thing maybe
we could lobby for an opting out because
we should be able to do that take 3000
oh no the price to my car if you don't
have been in there okay if I get come if
you get some control of it here you pay
the extra 3000 that I think we have an
image of the black box by the way let's
take a look and see what a black box
looks like it's not even by all that
it's just a little metal box you run
across it you have no idea well and you
know here's the thing too is that ok if
I mean almost every single I've been an
accident a long time yeah knock on wood
but um the two that I was in that were
bad the other person lied through their
teeth so in some ways it's like if this
thing does have true information and we
were all to use it in a really you know
justified way it could be it could be a
good thing of course but that's just
like the NSA stops right there right I
mean and if ever that's the thing and
then that's the problem with all the
spying analyst of the IFS are what we're
all afraid of and those are the things
that end up and that's what our
Constitution generally in the past used
to protect us against all of those gray
area ifs you know benefit of the doubt
kind of things and that is that's all
going away there's no more benefit of
the doubt for any of us you know we're
all in service of this other thing and
you know I was just thinking the other
day just even the term big data which is
what they use it's such a 1984
doublespeak thing it doesn't mean
anything it sounds cool iBM has
commercials about it it's got
aphex yeah it's got its own PR agency
obviously but it's if you know if I was
seeing to interview with Edward Snowden
this morning and it was like hearing him
talk and it was like wow when you get
down to what these people are really
really doing big data is just such a
whitewashing of what's going on it's
just yeah all right so we'll go with a
little jump off that then how much of
this is just they let us know about this
kind of stuff you know we find out about
the NSA stuff we find about black boxes
in our cars and phone tapping loss up
how much of it is actually not even the
literal stuff that they're doing but the
real value in it is just the fear that's
created around it you know you mean at
this point it makes no difference
whether they catch Snowden or whatever
but there's now a sense of fear you know
people have already said that the
informants are being quieter now people
are losing contact so it's really about
fear more than the specific little
instances right I mean of course if they
get the chance to get edward stone they
don't get them yeah but in the meantime
they're thinking well at least is not
gonna be any others cuz do you want to
go through this right you want to sit
nothing like the transit center russia
and we know how great Russia is right
he's definitely not wearing anything
with the rain warnings that one that
long to reconsider his lunch how sick of
Panda Express he must be like Woody is
he just have to go to the food court
every day like where is he really no
one's talking about it doesn't anyone at
Google glass at the russian air Moorea
borscht buffet this guy yeah exactly all
right let's get to the final story a lot
of technology this week Apple you have
heard of them you're probably watching
this on some sort of Apple device either
a macbook or an iPhone or an iPad or
something else uh they sold 31.2 million
iphones last quarter but believe it or
not they're not doing that well let's
take a look at some numbers so this is
apple sales and profit and you can see
uh that their profit has fallen twenty
two percent in the past quarter their
stock has dropped forty percent in the
last 10 months that that seems
completely crazy to me and in the
current quarter they're expected
underperform wall street expectations
and uh I think this leads to a lot of
interesting stuff because is this about
just sort of general technology fatigue
we've definitely had a theme in this
episode I didn't even intend on it being
that way uh is this general technology
fatigue is they're saying about Apple
that we're all starting to get a little
tired of you know they have this new
commercial now we're uh California made
in california and a warm and fuzzy yes
oh no does a mating company's his design
made right chain cuz they don't ever
have right because they don't say made
in China yes a designed in California it
feels very lovely it lays back and Steve
Jobs garage with him that's the kind of
vibe they're trying to get you to
reconnect to ya so are we having a
little apple fatigue right now that this
stuff we all have all of this stuff now
and that maybe they're becoming you know
they did that famous 1984 commercial way
back way tryna take down Microsoft but
now they've become the model it I'm I'm
willing to say I don't know where this
is coming from because I don't see any
fatigue amongst anybody I mean they may
get sick of the products at times but
they don't stop buying it I don't see
anything happening i'm alright it's cool
to say you're sick of it yeah you have
an iphone i assume no you don't i'm
gonna wrestle i'm one of those yeah what
do you got I'm gonna android i'm i'm at
the galaxy you wow i wish they would
have told me and we're in the same of
the fabric yeah but my girlfriend has
the exact opposite she has the ipad and
she has all that actually has the
macbook and all this stuff she puts that
side so still in the house so still
permeating the the finance is somewhere
in the house phone all right it works
that way so everyone has it connected
with it in some way but as we were
speaking about earlier what are you
gonna go to the next that is just as
much of a pain in your ass is the one
before and has eaten has their pluses
and their minuses yes I don't know how
this is going down again I'm stumped
yeah I think it's two things I think
there is a little bit of Apple fatigue I
think we have lost connection to the
brand because Steve Jobs died but I also
think this is a bunch of Wall Street
[ __ ] this is all this is to me this
is real is that that's why these active
dublin already
those numbers of the Year seven billion
dollars in profits isn't enough for all
streets right this is the endless cancer
growth that that Wall Street ones it's
about endless growth it's about endless
progress nothing on the planet of the
natural world has endless growth except
for cancer and Wall Street and we have
not we have no concept in our economy
anymore about limitations that if it
doesn't keep growing that if it's
plateauing it's all a fear it's like
this company is clearly going through
changes yes I think there is some
general fatigue about like what is the
you know when the ipod came out it was
like all gotta have that iphone gotta
have that i forgot yes they're there to
figuring it out what's gonna be the next
iteration in all of this but this is
Wall Street [ __ ] this is the stuff i
hate about our economy that it's run by
you know your your earnings each each
quarter right because there's we live
and die by these things right and that
is saying that they sold 31.2 million
iphones in the quarter that's an
incredible amount i think it might be
their best quarter ever and yet it's
still because of the wall street numbers
it still makes it seem like something
right yeah it's a skewed and it's a you
know a skewed standards and we've all
bought into oh we got to hear the the
wall street numbers the dow jones
numbers today and it's like this for the
most part is meaningless to ninety-nine
percent of us does the transition to the
transcend to consumers now to hear these
numbers and say oh i love apple products
right i need to go by i need to make
sure they stay afloat maybe maybe yeah
it's really messed up person if they're
like oh man Apple you yeah I think
you're thinking like is the mom and pop
shop down the street from where you grew
up you're like let's support our mom and
pop shops they can stay afloat do we
think that about the souper corporation
I have a little a little other version
of that which is we do try to find
meaning in these numbers because we
don't really are connected to them so we
think oh maybe Apple isn't doing as well
and and so I think maybe some people
then may pull back from the brand a
little bit to see like well maybe
they're not the coolest thing out there
let's see what's gonna happen you know
Google's got this you know all these
other weird shits coming out I do think
it's possible they're victim of their
own success in this way I actually got a
new macbook
err whatever a couple months ago when I
went into the store you know they greet
you immediately and the guy i knew i was
gonna get one it was very obvious from
the initial I wasn't you're not haggling
over price at Apple you're taking it and
that's it but I felt that the guy was so
dismissive like they know you're walking
in to buy it like they're so they think
they're so cool like yet you want this
thing let's just do this you know and
it's like maybe they actually are
suffering from their own success I've
had some bad service there and we've
we've gotten some response from some
managers because of that but the thing
is at Christmas time my husband and I
went to the mall and there was the apple
store and then there was a new Internet
Explorer store and they wear the
t-shirts like the apple store they had
designed it just like the apple store
there were two people customers in the
internet explorer store 25 guys working
there women working there we go you
couldn't even get near the apple store
there was a line to get in it was like
okay no matter what Apple's fine Apple's
doing fine they're doing oh yeah yeah
now how do we get you to get on Apple
cuz they need you man they need me okay
this is an these these are clean about
this were like every I just have my
things about iphone ipad users first of
all your phone is never charged every
time you come to anyone's house there's
BBQ there's a party does anyone have it
up and have a charger oh I like my
charger oh no I left in the car I said
well if it's never charged bring it with
you I'm Vicky this is hating on you guys
yeah but great just let it and let it
out but I cannon and is one of other
co-workers he got his iphone dropped at
the corner hit the floor it was a
carpeted store whole screenshot is the
screen made of like the thinnest in
glass I don't get it i've seen thirty
percent of people with iphones have a
cracked screen yeah well you'd have to
talk to the manufacturers in china
because it's only designed in California
sign the paper thin glass here but then
they created yeah exactly all right well
I want to thank my guest kelly Carlin
and junior Jackson oh I do want to by
the way you know I make fun of all the
time on Twitter all the factual errors
that CNN and all the news organizations
make and
might have made three tiny errors last
week's show and I want to address it
because I'm no bad this would be my
mayor culpa uh I pronounce the word
versus as verse and someone said its
verses I thought verse I thought it was
just very reading the comments I but
once it will because of the third one
that I'm gonna get to I don't read the
comments really but i did because of the
third one I made a real error so long
this is like see the new new pages
versus the indeed asked I said verse
okay I said something verse so that was
won by mistake I want to address that
and i will put that in my brain the next
one I said the word disingenuous which
is that not a word I thought to people
claimed it wasn't a word can anyone
confirm is it it is a word yeah all
right I retract that apology ok so now
Martinez alright apology to a [ __ ] you
and I guess okay and finally and this
one was sort of a slight factual error
we were talking about Twitter in France
and free speech and I somehow implied
that only the United States has free
speech but I was talking about our Bill
of Rights that we have the Bill of
Rights here obviously the United States
is not the only country to have free
speech and actually i'm not even sure we
have it here Samantha go anyway thank
you guys will do ya know subscribe
there's a button it's red it's right
down there click it these will come to
your emails it's nice and simple and
we'll do it again next week all right
thank you
you